[Music]
glass faucets elevate indoor plumbing to
an art form the glass is handcrafted in
a range of shapes and patterns for
visual effect metal components are fused
into the glass to deliver one of the
necessities of modern life running water
glass faucets are about both form and
function
[Music]
glass faucets have a delicate beauty but
they're stronger than they look
the glass is very thick allowing the
faucets to hold up to heavy use making a
glass faucet starts with chunks of clear
glass a glass worker loads the glass
into an oven at 2,000 190 degrees
Fahrenheit another worker selects black
and white billets of glass to add
stripes and patterns to the clear glass
he preheats them so the glass won't
shock and fracture when exposed to
higher temperatures with a metal rod he
gathers a clump of the clear glass from
the main oven with the chunk of glass he
picks up the preheated white cylinder
simultaneously exposing both to the
flames this process makes the glass
flexible using a curved wood tool the
glass worker gathers the clear glass at
the base and wraps it around the white
billet encapsulating it he attaches the
other end of the glass to a second metal
rod this allows the glass to stretch as
he pulls it across the room the glass is
now over 35 feet long and pencil-thin it
starts to cool and solidify immediately
as it's set down the glass workers tap
the glass against a piece of metal to
break it into eight inch pieces called
canes
they shape another piece of clear glass
by rolling it on a metal table called
the marver the glass worker blows
through the metal rod causing the glass
on the end to bubble it will eventually
become the faucet and two handles
[Music]
he adds a layer of black molten glass to
the bubble another glass technician
arranges the stripe canes on a grooved
iron plate and heats them with the torch
[Music]
meanwhile a glass worker rolls the hot
glass bubble onto the Cades which stick
together then it's back into the furnace
and the white stripe canes melt into the
black bubble next the craftsman rolls
the glass across the marver repeatedly
he pinches the kings at the top closing
them around the bubble the glass is
reheated to keep it pliable as the
craftsman continues to form it the
craftsman transforms the bubble into a
hollow glass tube then elongated the
tube to its desired length
using a pincer-like tool he forms the
end until round handle shape while
another glass worker applies heat to the
glass with a torch this keeps the glass
pliable he then creates a hole for a
piece of metal Hardware then he applies
molten glass to the metal hardware and
inserts the hardware into the round
faucet handle this cuts the handle free
from the rest of the glass using a
forming tool the craftsman refines the
shape of the glass
next he free heats a metal mold this
stops the hot glass tube from fracturing
as he bends it around the mold to shape
it into the faucet once the faucet has
taken shape it's ready to go into the
annealing oven
the glass is placed in the oven at a low
temperature and then cooled this process
removes stresses and strengthens that
glass meanwhile using high pressure
water that contains fragments of garnet
a craftsman cuts steel trim rings and a
display plate for the showroom next the
craftsman installs the glass faucet on
the display plate by threading a nut to
the faucet valve he installs the trim
rings at the base of the handles and
assembles them to the display plate
using the hardware that's been fused to
the inside of the glass the craftsman
uses a rag to clean the faucet of any
fingerprints and smudges finally
construction is complete this unique
glass faucet is ready to make a
statement